everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're gonna be
looking at the final day of the 2018
Tata Steel tournament and in round 13
there was a two-way tie going into the
final day Magnus Carlsen and a nice giri
both of those players ended up with a
draw and no one was able to catch them
so they get heads up in a tiebreaker
thought it would be more fun to go over
the tiebreaker series compared to going
over round three where they both drew so
this is Game one in the tiebreaker
Magnus Carlsen will be playing the white
pieces and then these giru will be
playing the black pieces this is a blitz
format meaning there is a 5 minutes time
limit on each of their clocks and they
do get three seconds added for every
move that they make now if you're
familiar with Magnus Carlsen you know
that he has won the Blitz World
Championship he is extremely talented at
fast chess play he's even run one the
rapid World Chess Championship so this
is his wheelhouse he does start game 1
they just played two games but this is
round one he starts out with the white
pieces so while we go through and
analyze some different positions just
know this is not the normal few hours to
look at moves so there are some some
situations where they take specific
lines where they probably would not have
taken those lines in an extended game
but Magnus Carlsen starts out with
Knight to f3 Knight to f6 and then pawn
to c4 pawn e6 and Magnus Carlsen has a
few options I was expecting more of the
pawn to d4 pawn to d5 getting into the
Queens gambit if we want to see the
Queens gambit accepted or not you know
couple options there or even Knight to
c3 if he wants to maybe hold on to the
thought that he could play the English
opening and not play pawn to d4 he could
wait to see where his opponent goes
Magnus Carlsen doesn't even worry about
what his opponent thinks he's gonna just
immediately play pawn to b3 so he's
definitely in at the English opening and
we see an HD replay
to d5 Bishop to b2 fing keto on to the
Queen side of the board trying to
dominate to these dark squares in at the
stern of the board Magnus Carlsen not
yet moving either of his central pawns
now we see Bishop to e7 getting ready to
castle on the kingside pawn to e3
opening up for the bishop on f1 to
control and protect the square here on a
c4 Castle met up to c3 pawn down here to
c5 and then we do see in exchange right
here a couple pieces come off the board
and then pawn up to d4 so Magnus Carlsen
has a similar type opening as you might
see in a Queens gambit accepted line
where he does have the the pawn here on
e4 and d4 but he has not quite got his
lights where bishop involved into the
game will be looking to that if he wants
to castle on at the King side Queen down
to a 5 and then Queen up to D 2 and both
sides decide now let's go ahead and
exchange material on the board once the
Queen's come off a little bit easier to
get your king involved you don't have to
worry about castling too much there's
not as much material to attack your King
so it doesn't need that safety so King
takes on d2 absolutely could have taken
with his knight if it does take maybe
pawn takes pawn or Bishop recaptures
Bishop down here to f5 Bishop e2 getting
ready to castle on the King side rook to
c8 so few options that magnus carlsen
had but the other day he decided yeah
I'm gonna want to get my King involved
into the game start an attack on my
opponent Knight to c6 we see a pawn take
bishop recapture bishop appear to be 5
so both sides have a bishop pair we do
see magnus carlsen with a better pawn
structure they are in two sets black has
this isolated pawn in the stern of the
board d5 not the best is going to have
to use his material to protect this
magnus carlsen can really attack this
for the rest of the game we do have
King's safety for dish Deary doesn't
matter too much he eventually will want
to get his King involved into the game
first decides to play Bishop to b4 check
King over here to e2 nice safe move
Bishop to e6
protecting that pawn rook to c1 both
sides getting their rooks involved into
the game where you would expect them to
be rook here to c8 both sides attacking
and trying to control this open sea file
rook to d1 attacking the semi open file
had other options I think it would have
been interesting if he played Bishop to
c6
after the pawn recaptures and that up
here to e5 is very dangerous for black
to deal with he has both the rook and
the night here on e5 attacking this pawn
but maybe Magnus Carlsen looked at this
and thought out of the lines too
difficult I have a good position here I
don't want to spend a lot of time
analyzing and trying to see if that
makes sense I only have five minutes on
my entire clock here so rook to d1 this
makes a lot of sense Bishop back here to
e7 pawn to h3 just does not want the
bishop to come to g4 pinned down his
Knights wants to be able to activate
this knight and get involved into the
siRNA board if possible pawn to a6
Bishop back here d3 Knight to be for
attacking the bishop bishop comes back
here to be one does not want to give up
his bishop here and leave his opponent
with a bishop here especially in an open
board state rook takes on c1 rook
recaptures on c1 we're over here to c8
now I thought Magnus Charleston may even
just decide let's exchange all material
the board but he does have the white
pieces he's not gonna have the white
pieces in the next game this is his one
shot so I don't think he wants to give
up all of his material and he decides to
play rook to d1 attacking that isolated
pawn here on d5 nice giri continues with
the knight coming back to c6 pawn to g4
Magnus Carlsen starting to get
aggressive on the King side the board
pawn age six Knight to the four
centralizing says now all exchange if
you want to and we do see an exchange
Bishop recaptures this is a great little
square for the bishop it's an outpost
gonna be difficult for black to get this
Bishop off the board and it's
controlling a lot of the board state
right now Bishop comes down here to a3
pawn here to F force manage caution
recognizing that he has a strong attack
once to continue the pressure he has
both of his bishops are Alling down on
the King
side so just wants to throw everything
at his opponent pawn to f6 trying to
stop some of the pressure by the darks
for a bishop on d4 Bishop up here to g6
King f8 King here to f3 King e7 so as we
talked about finally getting the King
into the center of the board
probably would have decided not to
Castle if he knew the Queen's were gonna
come off so early in the board state
pawn to h4 but you appear to be four so
and this year he doesn't have a strong
attack right now it almost seems like
he's trying to hold on play defense and
get to game 2 where he's gonna have the
white pieces he also hasn't lost a game
the entire tournament keep that in mind
a nice Giri has played a phenomenal
phenomenal Tata Steel tournament through
13 rounds Bishop comes down here to d3
Bishop up here to d7 Pawnee 4 you can
see Magnus Carlsen continue to push put
a lot of pressure on his opponents
Bishop down here c3 says yeah I would
like to exchange then I can get my rook
involved down in your neck of the woods
managed Carlson's not having any of that
Bishop down here 2ft wants to hold on to
his bishop here as long as possible
Bishop to c6 this is trying to defend
these center light squares would you see
the pond take the bishop take check and
then Bishop up here to e4 says yeah I
don't mind if you want to exchange right
now that's exactly what we see after the
King takes on e4 then King to e6 so both
sides have King all three pawns on the
King side of the board as well as two
pawns on the Queen side so both sides
are fairly even in material and I'll
just comes down to who plays a better
end game we see white continued pawn f5
the King moves back here to e7 rook to
c1 attacking the bishop the Brooks is
gonna come down to c6 it is protecting
it does not have to worry about the
bishop right now King to d3 adding
another attacker on the bishop so the
bishop is now forced to move bishop back
to b4 says yeah if you want to take my
rook that's fine
that's exactly what magnus carlsen does
pawn recapture so as far as the pawns
try
it does get a little interesting it's a
it's much more difficult for black to
hold on and protect both of these ponds
because they can't protect themselves
they these cheery now has to protect
that with either his bishop or his king
and he will need to get them on dark
squares to be able to protect him with
his bishop could always try a pawn to c5
he does have an outpost both the bishop
and his palm protect itself but then can
get a little defense and play pawn to a3
that's going to blow up that plan at
some point so King to c4 attacking the
bishop bishop back to d6 Bishop to c5 is
where this is such a huge move for
madness crossing very very difficult for
black to deal with this in the game he
decides to play King to d7 if he were to
take you can see how difficult it is the
bishop takes King takes here on a c5 and
then where does it plac go from here
well okay let's say you King to d7
trying to hold on to that much hero King
to b6 you can see this game is clearly
over White's gonna be able to gobble up
material here push his pawns this a pawn
very easy to promote up there to a8 King
to d6 King takes sure even if you want
to play King to c5 trying to trap some
material pawn to a5 it's not going to
matter King here to b6 getting ready for
the march up the board so this just puts
so much pressure Bishop to c5 on his
opponent a nice Giri running out of ways
to really move from here what good
options
does he have doesn't have a mini place
King to d7 and now pawn to h5 and this
is where Magnus Carlsen just adds even
more pressure says you don't have many
good moves on the Queen side the board
so I'm gonna make sure you don't have
any moves on at the Queen side of the
board as well also know that Magnus
Carlsen has pushed up further on it than
his opponent his Kings have moved up
three squares his pawns up for an H
teria have only moved up once so if
there is any sort of exchange Magnus
Carlsen always play something like pawn
to g5 at some point if we do see some
sort of exchange he may be able to win a
race since he doesn't have to
as far up at the board as a nice giri
the bishop comes down here to f4 bishop
up here to f8 attacking that pawn here
on a g7 King up to e8 Bishop down here
to see five and then King to d7 so we
are repeating one of the positions we
just saw a few moves ago and this
position Magnus Carlsen says yeah we did
definitely do not want to have a
three-fold repetition where if you have
the same board state three times it
would be a draw he recognizes that he
has the win in hand now he just has to
execute so he plays king to be 4 and
then Bishop over here to d2 check King
to a for now it's G enishi replays King
to c7 pawn before so this is stopping
the bishop from keeping this a 5 square
magnus carlsen really wants to play King
to a 5 couldn't do that with the bishop
going through and defending that so pawn
to b4 just a great square from Magnus
Carlsen also great outpost for his
Bishop the black really can't do too
much with Bishop to f4 now Bishop to f8
King to B 6 and then the bishop takes
material now it's gonna be much easier
if manage cross in place pawn to g5 to
push through just put so even more
pressure on his opponent King our Bishop
to g5 protecting both the bishops but
now in each tier is completely on a
defense mode right here
Bishop to f8 Bishop down here to f4 he
just doesn't have any good moves he
can't move either these ponds his king
as soon as he moves his King back he
can't move it to any of these squares if
he moves it back then immediately manage
cousins going to play King to a5 and it
just cuts off all the squares that in
each tier II would like to go to then
they can push his a pawn up it's just
not good so this forces the bishop to
come here to f4 Bishop to e7 Bishop
comes back to Jesus 5 King to b3 then
King to c7 and he should be running out
of options here we see the king to c4
to d7 and then Bishop back here to c5
King to c7
and you can start to see the few options
that a nice giri has King a to d3 King D
seven and then Bishop down here to e3
attacking the bishop and in this
position a nice giri did to decide to
resign its first lost in the tournament
some people always ask well how might
this continue if he doesn't take the
material okay Bishop to h4 then Bishop
takes on aged six
he's just gobbling up all the pawns on
the King side then he can easily move
his Bishop back start to push push his
pawns on the Kings side of the board if
and said we do see the bishop takes a
bishop takes III King recaptures then
where does black go from here
if he decides to play King to d6 okay
well King to d4 puts a stop to that the
King can't move to any of these squares
any of the pawn moves are gonna be
extremely bad cousin the pawn just gonna
recapture here on c5 or it's gonna
recapture here on a5 and then just push
up the board so the king is forced to
move can't come here to e6 so it's gonna
have to move back c7 then King to c5 if
it comes here to b7 sure pawn to g5 now
putting pressure if it takes okay take
and then I'm just gonna push up the
board you can't stop that if we come
back and say after the exchange then
maybe King back to d8 same thing King up
here to d4 there's no way to stop the
threat so nice you saw this also didn't
have a ton of time and said Magnus
Carlsen you win this game game number
two not as exciting Magnus Carlsen was
able to get an easy draw and so Magnus
Carlsen is the victor he wins his sixth
tata steel tournament which is an
amazing accomplishment so
congratulations to Magnus Carlsen
he tends to always win or get second in
the tournament if he plays it which is a
phenomenal feat knowing that there's so
many strong players managed Carlsen just
above the rest of the field right now in
the world we are only a couple months
away in March for the candidates
tournament and that is where we will
have eight competitors some of the top
players in the world competing the
winner of that will play Magnus Carlsen
later this year for the World
Championship so be looking for coverage
of that but until next time thanks again
for watching and I'll see you guys later